[Musique]
bonjour je suis hors des lamas qu'angela
je suis développeur de formation à la cm
à essen une inscription en quelques
clics vous permet de connaître et
d'utiliser les droits à la formation que
vous avez cumulé
allez je vous explique tout rendez vous
sur le site mon compte formation point
gouv.fr ou sur l'application mobile
si vous n'avez pas encore de compte vous
pouvez en créer un facilement à l'aide
de votre numéro de sécurité sociale si
c'est déjà fait connectez-vous
directement le tour est joué vous
connaissez désormais vos droits et vous
pouvez rechercher des formations
adaptées à vos envies
imaginons vous souhaitez créer votre
entreprise et vous avez besoin de vous
formez vous pouvez utiliser
l'application mon compte formation dans
la barre de recherche
renseignez l'intitulé de la formation
par exemple parcours créateurs ou pâques
préciser si vous recherchez une
formation en centre ou à distance
sélectionner le lieu où vous souhaitez
effectuer votre formation à evry ou à
étampes
et pour terminer cliquez sur trouvez
vous verrez apparaître les différentes
formations proposées par la chambre de
métiers et de l'artisanat vous avez
besoin de plus de renseignements de
conseils pratiques profitons-en pour
faire le point sur vos besoins de
formation avec les conseillers de la cmm
[Musique]